لجنه التحقيق العراقيه بما وصف بفضيحه
سرقه ضباط للرفض الخام في محافظه البصره
تكشف عن اليات وطرق عمليات التهريب وبيع
النفط المسروق قضيه النفط تورط فيها تسعه
ضباط في وزاره الداخليه تتراوح رتبهم بين
لواء رائد شاركوا شبكه واسعه لسرقه النفط
الخام في محافظه البصره الجنوبيه جهاز
الامن العراقي اطلع لجنه التحقيق على
معلومات استخباراتيه جزئيه بشان قضيه
التهريب قالت ان حلول الليل كان شرطا
لاتمام عمليات السرقه وبشكل يومي والدوره
المنوط بالضباط يعتمد على حمايه المهربين
اثناء احداثهم ثغرات بالخطوط الناقله ثم
مدي انابيب منها الى اماكن تحميل النفط
عبر شاحنات تقوم بدورها بتهريبه الى اقليم
كردستان الشمالي ومنه الى سوريا ودول اخرى
حيث يتم بيعه يحصل باطو بالمقابل على نحو
320.000$ حصيله ثغره انبوب واحد وتقدر
كميات المهربه يوميا من خمسه الى سبعه
صهاريج بسعه 50,000 لتر للخرق الواحد فيما
يقدر عدد الصهاريج المهربه من 40 الى 50
صهريجا بمعدل 75 مليون لتر شهريا اللافت
ان عمليات سرقه وبيع النفط لا تقتصر على
محافظه البصره بل ومنذ سنوات تتردد
معلومات في تقارير محليه عن عمليات سرقه
وتهريب للنفط ومشتقاته في معظم المحافظات
العراقيه التي يتوفر بها الذهب الاسود